what's the next vertical that you're
gonna get done here I mean I was
thinking art but art is got so many
incumbents who do not want you involved
craft but comic books yeah and
collectibles in that area yeah now
that's a winning idea yeah that's
exactly where we're going okay great all
right everybody I've just guests welcome
to guess the road map it's funny when
it's like you hear a thousand pitches a
year it's pretty easy to guess so you're
gonna do comic books and collectibles
next that makes a little sense movie
collectibles that kind of stuff yeah
sports as well really huge and we really
like wine whiskey and watches as well
wine yeah total sense see the more
fragmented the space correct the better
it is for you there's nobody controlling
supply or it you have people controlling
supply correct and the lower the price
per item and the more number of items
that means there's more velocity exactly
so cars there's a lot of cars a lot of
different makes a lot of different years
a lot of different conditions and comic
books and wine there are billions of
copies of comic books and bottles of
wine so you've got an unlimited
opportunity so you're saying you could
go buy a bunch of screaming eagle or
Opus one sure and then you have to
maintain it that's a little expensive
that's a couple of dollars per bottle
per year mmm and you have to validate it
so which ones which one I'm gonna do
next you think I'm em really isn't
collectible yeah that makes total sense
what's great about that too is if you do
a storefront and you do all the simpsons
collectibles you got something going
exactly oh my god what a great idea how
many people work there now about 20 20
perfect well in New York all in New York
we've got a few of our developers remote
but for the most part in New York City
and our HQ is right above our showroom
it makes total sense
see I think retail have a really great
investment right now in a chemical
neighbourly they're taking Rio you know
it they're taking retail locations and
turning them into community spaces or
you know essentially what would be we
work of storefronts yes and they're in
our accelerator right now and it's just
some love with the idea that you have
all this like on Lafayette Street like
there's only so many gaps and
young banks and coffee shops the only
things that money anymore it's not gonna
be a hardware store or a Radio Shack
like Darrell gone or a pet store like
they're gonna go away to like Amazon's
killing everything she can have this
extra retail so I'm guessing you got a
sick deal we did any and we actually
have them as on store around the corner
from us as well so right